SAAD ALI: Hi, everyone.
My name is Saad Ali.
I'm a software
engineer at Google.
And today I have Wes.
He's a product manager
at Google with GKE.
Wes, I understand you've been
working on the on-prem product
for Google.
WESTIN HUCHINS: Yeah,
so last Cloud Next
was down in San
Francisco around July.
And we unveiled
GKE On-Prem, which
is a product that I've been
working on for quite some time
and trying to bring Kubernetes
or an opinionated Kubernetes
installation to an
on-prem environment.
It's something we heard
from a lot of customers,
that they really wanted to
solve for hybrid scenarios
where they had workloads
that they couldn't quite
move to the Cloud.
But they really wanted the power
of GKE, all of the management
features that come
with GKE, and they
wanted it-- to package
it up and put it
in their own environment.
And so we've kind of
been working on that
and taking that idea forward.
And that's sort of the
beginnings of GKE On-Prem.
SAAD ALI: That
sounds super awesome.
So let's dig into
it a little bit.
What does it actually look like?
How does it work?
WESTIN HUCHINS:
Yeah, so GKE On-Prem,
the fundamentals for it are
actually based a lot on open
source--
both open source Kubernetes,
but a new project
that's spun up in the open
source called the Cluster API.
So this is something that
we've gotten a lot of help
from the community.
Kris Nova at Heptio has
been one of the main drivers
behind the Cluster API.
But we brainstormed this
idea a long time ago
around making
infrastructure declarative.
And it was kind of a new idea
at the time for Kubernetes.
We had like 40 or
50 installers and we
found they were all
doing their own thing.
And we were like,
well, is there a way
that we can take all
the lessons we've
learned around abstracting
out infrastructure, making it
into a Kubernetes
compatible API,
and provide a nice
lightweight layer for us
to build a cluster spec?
What does a cluster look like?
How are the machine's
provisions--
this all was the genesis
of the Cluster API, which
is now forming the underpinnings
for how we build GKE On-Prem.
So GKE On-Prem actually
uses a lot of the machinery
that we've used in the
open for Cluster API.
We define what we want
the cluster to look like.
We have a cloud
provider plug-in model.
Right now, we're supporting
VMware using vSphere
as our underlying IaaS layer.
But really one of the nice
features of the Cluster API
is its extensability.
So while the scope
right now is on VMware,
there's opportunity for a lot
of the other cloud providers
to plug in and make
GKE On-Prem run
across these different
environments.
SAAD ALI: And what
kind of capability
is the Cluster API and GKE
On-Prem going to enable?
WESTIN HUCHINS:
It's really going
to enable people to treat
clusters more like cattle,
is one of the big
underpinnings of it.
It's like we've
been trying to say--
if you can define what the
shape and size of your cluster,
check that into Git-Repo
or something like that,
you have sort of a
reproducible cluster.
And if we can automate spinning
those things up and tearing
them down, and automate the idea
of adding nodes and removing
nodes, baking in some of
the node pull concepts
that we offer in GKE,
well, this allows
us to be much more
flexible in how
teams go in provision clusters.
Quite frankly what
I've seen when
I talk to a lot of customers is
they have these clusters that
are really long lived.
Someone's like, well, I
need to keep my cluster up
for two to three years
sometimes because I never
want to touch it.
I just keep rolling upgrades.
The problem is is
that at some point
you may hit features that do
require a cluster rebuild,
and the Cluster API really makes
that process of standing up
a new cluster much easier.
SAAD ALI: OK.
So it sounds like Google
is using the Cluster
API to be able to provision
these on-prem clusters.
It's going to enable
the power of everything
we have in Google Cloud
to show up in On-Prem.
What are some of
the other components
that make up On-Prem?
WESTIN HUCHINS: Yeah.
So the real power
of GKE On-Prem is
that it's an on-prem
Kubernetes product that
is managed by Google.
So there's this connection
back to our cloud.
We actually use a lot
of our Cloud Console
and our other container services
that run inside the Cloud
in order to make sure that
your cluster is healthy
and also to make
sure that you can
utilize a lot of the
cloud-based tools
that we've built for containers,
things like CI/CD, our Cloud
Build product, any of
our security products
that work well with GKE, and
treat the GKE On-Prem cluster
sort of as an
extension of a zone.
It's just another cluster
that runs-- it just happens
to run inside your data center.
SAAD ALI: And so if you have a
large on-premise data center,
you could potentially use the
Cloud to burst workloads into?
WESTIN HUCHINS: Oh, absolutely.
You'll start to
see us really start
to invest more
around multi-cluster
tooling and making
these actions where
it's like we can build tools
that migrate from one cluster
to another.
You can choose to run certain
workloads in the Cloud
that take advantage of
things like GPUs and CPUs.
Or you could keep things
local for data sovereignty,
regulatory compliance reasons.
Those types of
features are really
what we want to light
up with GKE On-Prem.
SAAD ALI: That super exciting.
When can customers begin
to play around with this?
WESTIN HUCHINS: We
are actively driving
towards a mid-2019
release for GKE On-Prem.
We are already
working with a number
of early design customers
and alpha customers
getting this deployed inside
their lab environment.
So, yeah, we're still iterating.
We're still looking for
good feedback on it,
but we're driving
towards a 2019 release.
SAAD ALI: Cool.
And is that the
most exciting thing
that you're excited
about in the next year?
WESTIN HUCHINS: I mean,
absolutely, right?
It's going to be a big--
this is honestly a massive
release for Google as a company
because it really starts to
sell the vision of where we're
going with true
hybrid environments
and getting customers an
onboarding path onto Google
Cloud.
SAAD ALI: That sounds awesome.
So switching gears a
little bit, what are you
most excited about at KubeCon?
WESTIN HUCHINS: I really
am interested in hearing
Bryan Green and Tim Hawkins
talk a lot about the early days
of Kubernetes.
You know--
SAAD ALI: The war stories.
WESTIN HUCHINS: I know I've
heard a lot from Joe and Craig,
and I'm interested to hear
how it got made inside Google.
Being a Googler for
quite some time,
I know some of the
different hoops
you have to jump through, so I'm
really interested in checking
that out.
I think it's later
today or something
like that, where they're
going to talk about that.
SAAD ALI: Awesome.
I'm looking forward
to that, too.
Thanks a lot, Wes.
WESTIN HUCHINS: Awesome.
Thank you.
SAAD ALI: Take care.